انا الناس في السعوديه ماذا تحفظون من
ابيات الشعر
امات الحب عشاقا وحبك انت احياني ولو خيرت
في وطن لا قلتها واقطعني ولو انساك يا
عمري حنايا القلب تنساني اذا ما ضعت في
دربك ففي عينيك عنواني هذه اول ابيض شعر
انا حفظتها في حياتي وبمناسبه انه هذا
العام هو عام الشعر خلينا نشوف الناس ايش
حافظه من ابيات الشعر
للامانه اول شيء خطر على بالي الان
قم للمعلم وفيه التبجيله كاد المعلم ان
يكون رسوله للمتنبي الخيل والليل والبيداء
تعرفني والسيف والرمح والقرطاس والقلم
ما تشاء وتطب نفسا اذا حكم القضاء
كشعر او عام الشعر عربي يستحضر فيه طبعا
كبار الشعراء خصوصا في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
رمز الشعر الامير بدر بن محسن الامير عبد
الرحمن المساعد لم يتخلى الفيصل الامير
عبد الله الفيصل احد رواد الشعر العربي
طبعا
ما عاد بدري تدري العمر مره سرقه سنينه
مني للاحظات قولي احبك كي تزيد وسامتي
فبغير حبك لا اكون جميله
[موسيقى]